[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody and welcome to another
episode of outdoor boys and we're
getting ready for a massive road trip
we're gonna spend the next 10 days
driving from Northern Virginia down to
Jackson Mississippi and stop it along
the way and having some serious fun
we're gonna be fishing for giant
stripers blue catfish we're gonna be
just having a great old time so this is
gonna be Jacob's first road trip and
he's excited we're gonna have a good
time and I'm packing up my camera
equipment here I've got three GoPros two
DL DL SRS a bunch of accessories got to
get my fishing gear ready downloading a
ton of stuff for the kids on their
Kindles to keep them entertained and
it's gonna be a great practice for when
we go traveling the world here in a
couple months so we're gonna be going to
Japan Utah Alaska British Columbia and a
few other places so we better get used
to traveling because this happened in
this summer
alright guys so we've got to get a
family of five and all of our luggage
for a ten day trip in this car we're
gonna see what happens I'm gonna have to
use all of my dad's skills
[Applause]
guys you ready to go yeah
[Music]
see
Wow we're like half a mile into this
state is already a Bass Pro Shop
that's impressive that's a good state
right there well we're doing pretty good
we're about five and a half hours into
the trip but this little guy needs a
diaper change don't you Jacob in a boot
store we can get Tommy cowboy boots that
[Music]
rainbows over my Dick's Sporting Goods
there must be a fishing gear sale and
look it's Dolly Parton stampede best
dinner theater in the country listen
guys there are no bears in this area
today we're not going to get attacked by
bears
there's just something parents tell us
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alright guys look at this place Tommy
this is awesome and like there's dancing
bears there's bears everywhere here this
place is infested with bears you guys
want to go see upstairs he went upstairs
oh hey Tommy look at this look at this
you're gonna love this there's a video
game and a pool table look at this it's
your bedrooms look at this how cool are
these bedrooms oh look at this guy's
do you know what this is look at this
it's a movie theater room it's your own
personal movie theater there are you
I'm looking out here we got the jacuzzi
tub I am so proud of my boys eight hours
in the car and they were awesome you
guys did a great job
[Music]
how's that for cute yeah that's a boy
who's ready to go into a pool for the
first time ever you guys ready to go
swimming in you go buddy all right guys
well the rest of the families hid in the
pool I'm gonna go to the grocery store
pick up some supplies so we have snacks
tomorrow breakfast and all that stuff
well it's raining it's raining good well
we didn't know this but apparently
Pigeon Forge is a bit of a tourist town
there's lots of little carnivals and
there's Dollywood and tons of fun things
to do with the kids we really wish we
had spent more time there
[Music]
oh well it's 4:30 in the morning and
we've got to get up super early to go
meet Scott Manning to go fishing for
giant stripers and blue catfish you
tired bud yeah you can sleep a little
bit in the car okay it's about an
hour-and-a-half drive as you get you I'm
gonna attack it so hard ready to go
fishing for big striped bass awesome
right I gotta admit I don't even know
what body of water this is in the boat
but nice setup
thank you very much bet I know what I
know how that goes do you promise
somebody gonna take him and you just
feel like crap yeah
all right look at that another beauty I
might keep one of these in hook him up
there I'm point you get there you a time
you want to reel them in yeah it's a
good one there's nothing
yeah you look at that but Oh got a
little blood on him so you gotta be
gentle with them unless we're gonna eat
him no no all right let's put so you
take out this big live well they got Tom
look at how big that is
man this is just every cast feelings are
get striper is it's a Stryper Stryper in
a boat look at that
yeah we're gonna cook this tell mommy
let's go put them in the live well okay
we're kind of like a culinary Noah's Ark
here what do you think of this top is
this worth getting up at 4:30 in the
morning good job you let that one you
let that one go for dad pull it in here
Tommy
[Music]
it's gonna be like number 20 we've been
doing this for 30 40 minutes tell me you
tired yeah catch all those fish was a
lot of work wasn't it caught what maybe
like 20 or 30 of them I think you have a
good time
high five buddy good job I've ever meet
awesome thank you cutting up some fresh
skipjack hearing they're sorry Tommy
let's see you hadn't popped up yet
that's a good sign these just feisty
awesome
this this spot just guys that was the
most amazing fishing action we caught
more white bass than we could count just
had a ball and we've got a couple in the
live well so we're gonna take them
upstream build a campfire Flay them up
and cook them
[Music]
well guys we found ourselves a lovely
little spot here on the river got a
little fire going hopefully we'll have
some coals soon I need to start cutting
some fish so I'm just telling these guys
I've never filleted a crappie before and
they go oh we can help you with that so
we're gonna we're gonna give this a go
all right I got the striper white bass
white crappie so I'm gonna do is gonna
put some fish here in this little PETA
squeeze a little lime on this put some
cilantro in there peppers tomatoes
onions maybe crabs some greens in there
too if there's some room bill tajiki
sauce we're gonna try this out that's
pretty good that's pretty good for a
pretty ghetto cooking skills here he
wants a board like it and special
shout-out to captain Scott Manning and
Tennessee River Monsters for putting us
on some awesome fish they're gonna be a
link in the description to their website
you guys want to have a trip like this
just call them they'll hook you guys up
you're gonna be game
I'm glad you came too buddy fun little
fact I met Scott for the first time at
the first annual catfish conference and
he is the one who actually gave me this
hat when it was white and brown when I
got it yes I think that hey look what he
just hooked me up with then thank you
very much thank you brother did you have
fun I had a great time man whoo you
might need some sunscreen though I'm
feeling roasted let's go home see mom
and Nathan and Jacob and let's go play
in the pool but well you know you had a
good time when only half of you come
back wearing pants all right buddy let's
go inside
well me and Tommy got back from fishing
like 15 minutes ago and lucky we did
because as soon as we got here it just
started pouring buckets
look at this got a thunder and lightning
and just gorgeous and cozy what do you
guys think is this cool to sit on the
back porch we've been so lucky with the
weather it was pouring buckets last
night
[Music]
lori's buckets right now I think the
only good weather we had was a few hours
we were fishing oh nice nice and
weather's perfect just takes the edge
right off the heat take some of this big
pile of that all right there we go
so there you go guys there is a
beautiful striped bass po-boy slider
with a little coleslaw
it's a macaroni salad I love these
little cabins or a condo or something
where you can buy your own food and make
your own we don't have to eat out all
the time but it does force you into some
weird dietary choices so I bought an
entire key lime pie because it looked
amazing it is amazing but we're checking
out in slightly over 24 hours and so we
don't eat it all it's just gonna go to
waste so like half a key lime pie today
you tie your Tommy Oh exhausted it's
4:30 in the morning and we're up again
I'm dead well 6:30 in the morning and
we're getting ready to go on another
great day of fishing now Scott is
horribly under the weather he pulled
himself off his sickbed to take us
yesterday right so he's taking a little
break and a friend of his he's taking us
out today
doing well careful jump on
yesterday when Scott told me he would be
taking me he said don't worry I got Vin
Diesel to do it for it for me so there
we go there we go then triple we got xxx
cab
you know you almost had me going there
for a while
don't let a snark this one off we could
do the last one keep growing in size
like that yeah Tommy you're doing well
bud okay you want to hold this one too
boy all right Tom make sure yeah look at
that is they having fun bud I gotta tell
you guys I would hire these guys just
for this seat just for the seat this is
oh who's my bottoms new best friend
right here oh there we go fish right
there buddy I'll hold your sandwich
there we go
had a great time this is just a great
charter very family-friendly here great
boat to be on so if you guys want to
check out more information about these
guys check out deuces wild fishing
charters they've got a YouTube channel
Facebook Instagram I'll put links in the
description thank you very much ARP
right there see you carp right there hey
that looks a little different he might
be a buffalo might be a buffalo not a
carp look at this bud
a couple root beer float sounds really
good have you ever had a root beer float
before bud yeah I thought this might be
your first only 15 more miles huh
all right buddy you were to go inside
all right let's do it
hey I know I had some grandiose plans
about doing various things tonight that
I'm really exhausted and so I'm just
gonna chill with my little boys here and
do relaxing things for a while
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
right round baby right round like a
record baby right round round round
well guys Tommy really wanted to keep
swimming with mommy so I have Jacob and
Nathan and we're going to do a little
looking around and maybe go get
ourselves some cowboy boots what do you
think yeah look at that place that's
huge we're at a place called Smoky
Mountain knife works it's massive it
claims to be the largest knife store in
the world from the size of it I believe
it looks like a small Cabela's dedicated
just two knives so check it out guys
there you go Nathan you're doing a
really good job buddy yeah this is just
machetes look at these you got the spear
up there they got the machetes
[Music]
nah believe this you know these are
that's a shinai that's a kendo sword
yeah this is a practice sword yeah look
at the samurai sword this is a ninja
sword oh look they have an entire
section just for nunchucks
yeah nice Gladius that's cool holy
mackerel this place is got even more
stuff look at this so you know there's
an elephant and there's a key buffalo
that's crazy
yeah listen buddy you got enough fishing
rods you don't need to buy you know six
easy to cool these do the type of
pocketknife we're gonna get you when you
and you are old enough to not stab your
brother yeah those are those are nice
axes look at that that is gorgeous
Oh place is huge I said this was like a
small Cabela's this is like a large
Cabela's this place is enormous it's
like three stories of knives there's an
alligator over there
yeah alligators they've got all these
like historic displays too they don't
just sell knives this place is like a
museum to
I completely underestimated this place I
spent about 40 minutes in there I needed
like four hours there is a crazy amount
of knives in there oh well there were
some axes I really really wanted I don't
need any more axes I really don't I
wanted them alright man if I wasn't
inside I wish I had more time there was
so much stuff in there all right guys I
told the boys we could get him a pair of
cowboy boots so we're gonna go see see
what they got all right Nathan Nathan
out of that puddle oh my goodness I have
no idea what even we get look at this
place there this is a ton of boots what
do you think what do you think about
these those all right there we go I
think we got a pair you like those boots
you strutting around in those cowboy
boots I think we should stick the ones
we picked out for you all right guys we
got buy one get two free to got boots
for all the boys it's past the boy's
bedtime we gotta get these little
Cowboys home you like your cowboy boots
all right let's go home
[Music]
hey guys you like your boots look at
that
we look like Cowboys well it's our final
night here at the cabin it's wonderful
but it is late it's like what 11:30 or
something like that and we are cleaning
and packing and getting everything ready
because we've got to leave early
tomorrow we got an eight-hour drive to
Mississippi so I'll sleep when I'm dead
it's another beautiful day and I am sad
to be leaving this place we cooked up a
big mess of breakfast and this is my
view of the back porch that's why they
call them the Smoky Mountains
[Music]
I packed it we are ready to go I know
it's Sunday so I'm gonna go take the
kids to church then we're gonna head out
to Mississippi oh wow
always got to leave growing room in the
back of your car on road trips cuz it
always gets bigger
alright Cowboys you ready alright let's
ride saddle up and ride out well we had
a good time at church we flooded the
bathroom and we lost our child but we're
really proud of Tommy because he
remembered his phone number and and
people called us but we didn't have our
phones on so you know whatevs whatevs
great Sunday but we're on the road we're
headed to Mississippi now time to flee
the state we have Tennessee's been a
blast let's go check out Alabama briefly
and cruise on to Mississippi if you'd
like to see more great outdoor Boys
videos including all the videos from
this southern road trip check out the
link in the description and don't forget
to click subscribe we put out new videos
every week and join us every Saturday
morning for a new adventure from the
outdoor boys thanks for watching